hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh may 31st [ __ ]
flying through this year 2021
what's going on how why yeah
how's it going i hope you're good i hope
you're doing well and all of that
[ __ ] i'm doing pretty good here um
that's oh man i something happened to me
this [ __ ] morning that i swear to god
man back in the day
all right meaning about [ __ ] six
months ago
oh i would have carried this one
oh i would have carried this one there's
if there's one thing
i cannot [ __ ] stand
it's a passive aggressive [ __ ]
and you know what sucks is for some
reason when i'm on stage
if someone tries and pull that tries to
pull that [ __ ] or play the victim or
whatever
i don't know what it is i'm [ __ ]
locked in
and very rarely does it get past me
but the second i get off stage i am defy
you just all day long
i'm a day late and a dollar short by the
time i figure out wait a minute that
person was being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i [ __ ] i i got to get better at that
[ __ ] listen to this right
so um
i'm hanging out with my daughter we're
having a great time we're riding bikes
and all that type of stuff and she goes
hey can you take me to this park and
this park she likes
it's you know it's a ways away we went
there the other day there was a bunch of
traffic yada yada yada
so i go hey why don't we go if we're
going to drive that far
you know let's go over to this other
place
right it has these [ __ ] rides and all
of this [ __ ] right so like an
idiot i forgot that it was sunday
and i also forgot that it was memorial
day weekend
so i go over there and anybody with the
kid is just there
and there just to the ticket booth
is like a [ __ ] it looks like an hour
long line
right hour and a half long hour hour and
a half right
and you know but you know once the kid
sees the ride it's it's [ __ ] over you
can't be like
you know you can't be like oh you know
the lines are too long we're gonna come
back
tomorrow the next day they're not having
it so i'm like
all right here we go one of these dad
things all right so i stand in this
[ __ ] line and we're standing there
standing there standing there standing
there finally get the [ __ ] tickets
then you get the tickets and then you're
standing there standing there all of
this [ __ ]
um finally got to go on some rides and
stuff like that whatever we have a good
time i get i get a little [ __ ]
snow cone and we're walking back to the
cars we go to get to the car there's
this couple just
rushing i mean like they robbed a bank
they put their bicycles on top of the
car or whatever they had the doors open
they're glancing at me and they're right
next to my car
all right so i open up
you know the kid's seat you're supposed
to have the kids seat in the same side
you drive because they say god forbid
somebody comes at you
there's a tendency to save yourself just
instinctually
and you don't want to turn the car
broadside and have them t-bone your kid
so you want
your kid to be with you getting the [ __ ]
out of the way so
you know i see the woman sort of clock
me trying to get in there and she's
uh you know doing her [ __ ] right
um they close up they're really rushing
to get the [ __ ] out of there right so
i'm like all right whatever you know
when i open the door and i'm putting my
kid in
and the guy walks by me and he goes
we're about to leave
he looks at me because we're about to
leave you know as i'm opening the door
[ __ ] face all red sweaty [ __ ] right
and i
[ __ ] i'm thinking like all right so i
closed the door
you know so they can get past and i got
in the other side
of the car to like strap her into thing
and they're like backing up he sort of
looks at me you know of course he's not
driving his wife is
[ __ ] [ __ ] right and they drive away
and then it just hits me like
we're about to leave the [ __ ] does that
mean
i'm about to put my kid in the car you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we're about to leave what the [ __ ] does
that mean
right so now i'm [ __ ] driving the car
i don't give a [ __ ] you're about to
leave what the [ __ ] is we're about to
leave
somebody for [ __ ] for the love of god
explain to me what the [ __ ] we're about
to leave means
that means don't open the [ __ ] door i
want to back out and i want to [ __ ]
wait for you
because i got [ __ ] to do
right oh stupid freckles figures this
out
after he gets out of the way like i work
for the guy
oh god you ever watch sports and the go
you know he really he really wishes he
could have that one back
why don't you guys write me in to
moments like this you wish you could
have it back
what you did or what you said and what
you wished you did
and what you wish you said cause this is
what i wish i didn't wish i would i wish
i said oh jesus
we're about to leave i i should i wish i
said yeah i'm about to put my kid in the
car
what are you telling what am i am i
supposed to be documenting what you're
about to do
with your red sweaty face why don't you
sit down before you
see i can't say because my kid was there
this is what i'd say my kid wasn't there
you know my kid couldn't hear if he had
the [ __ ] ear much like vince vaughn
in [ __ ] uh old school
we're about to leave yeah i'm about to
put my kid in the [ __ ] car
all right you sweaty [ __ ] why don't you
get in your [ __ ] car and shut the
[ __ ] up and when i'm done
you [ __ ] back up
oh god that [ __ ] pissed me off after
after but in the moment what did i do oh
okay i closed the [ __ ] door and i got
around he [ __ ] gives me a look as he
[ __ ] he's giving me a look
oh jesus christ that [ __ ] pissed me
off
and here's the thing but here's the
[ __ ] thing
okay if i said what the [ __ ] i wanted to
say
or really what my temper makes me say
because he reminds me of people from my
childhood that's what's really going on
there what i what i
if i said well whatever i'm gonna put my
kid in the car you sweaty [ __ ] [ __ ]
then everybody look at me he's like i
can't believe the guy just snapped like
that
he just said that in front of his kid
and then i'm the [ __ ] [ __ ]
right and that's what i hate about
passive aggressive people
we're about to leave we're about to
leave and
he's watching me put a child in the car
and he's such a selfish [ __ ] he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
he doesn't want to deal with me opening
the door and them having to slowly back
out of the [ __ ] space
dude you should have seen them rushing
out of there it was like they found out
you know they've been stealing money and
the feds were about to get to their
house they were trying to beat them
there
so you could start shredding documents
so i guess empathetically maybe they had
somewhere to be i don't know
but there was no please
hey sorry i mean we're about to leave
then we just like back i know you put
your kid in i'm i'm really sorry just
we're late
just something like that we're about to
leave
and what the [ __ ] is wrong with me that
that's all he needed to say to me and i
turned into like his [ __ ] servant
[ __ ] can't stand passive aggressive
people like that i they [ __ ]
annoy as you can tell they annoy the
[ __ ] on me which is
why this week i'm watching the real
housewives of potomac
because i've finally just given in
that like you know i you know what am i
gonna do she's not gonna stop watching
these shows
i might as well start watching right so
over the years
when i've been watching these [ __ ]
lunatic chicks
screaming and yelling each other and
just saying
the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] you could
possibly say to another human being
what has always pissed me off is when
finally somebody lunges across the
[ __ ] table
to give somebody the [ __ ] beatdown
they so
richly deserve
a bunch of people come in and break it
up
before it can even go down it takes me
all the way back
to when uh whatever the [ __ ] flavor flav
called that blonde chick
spit in miss new york's face
and then just turned around like nothing
was going to happen because you know why
because she's never gotten her ass
kicked
that's how [ __ ] up that chick was she
spit in another human being's face
and didn't jump back she just did an
about face like she made a good point
and started to walk away and miss new
york was about to snatch her by her
[ __ ] hair and then all these other
people came in to break it up
and they let her get away with it
they let her get away with that level of
[ __ ] behavior
and that's why i don't watch that [ __ ]
because it drives me up i [ __ ] hate
passive aggressed people guess what
guess what the thing that i always
wanted to have happened happened
this [ __ ] chick i forget her name she
looks like lady from lady in the [ __ ]
right she looks just like that cocker
spaniel
is just being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
passive aggressive though doesn't have
the courage to just be an [ __ ]
is being a passive aggressive [ __ ]
now in defense of her
i kind of came in on this episode but i
see this [ __ ] clip
where she's over the other woman's house
she's hugging her husband
the other woman's pretending monique is
pretending to be asleep
okay now i would think as a woman if you
just hug somebody's husband and the
other one's pretending to go to sleep it
doesn't even say goodbye
you cross some sort of line and maybe
you ought to [ __ ] tone it down
or have a talk but she doesn't
she doesn't they go out to this [ __ ]
i don't know what it was it looked like
a set
it was allegedly a [ __ ] wine bar i
don't know what
and they're out there and they're
[ __ ] you know drinking wine having
some cheese everybody's got their little
outfits on
and the lady the lady there lady the
[ __ ] cocker spaniel starts [ __ ]
yipping
at the monique check right and it's just
going and going and going
and then the little cocker spaniel who
for whatever reason is wearing a leopard
print
starts prancing around what are you
gonna drag me you're gonna i guess that
means get your
kick my ass drag me you're gonna drag me
right
so monique chick
goes yeah i'll drag and she flips her
[ __ ] little [ __ ] carcass spaniel
ears hanging down right she gives him a
couple of [ __ ] flips
which is a clear warning of
you know this is america there's three
strikes and you're out she did one flip
two flips right america's past time take
me out to the ball game right and then i
don't know what happened i think
uh whatever her name she grabbed monique
and then that was it
that was [ __ ] it and
i'm gonna tell you something right now i
don't know how many people were trying
to pull
monique off of off of this disney star
but it they needed another whatever
times two or whatever they had because
she [ __ ] grabbed her slammed her face
down
onto this table
and was just bam bam bam to the back of
the head i want to say it was open hand
i hope it was close but it was
open-handed
and then when the beating was done she
just held her down on the table
and this was the funny thing there was
all these people going monique monique
let her go let her go and she would not
let her go it looked like you ever see
like when a hawk
is standing on a pigeon and it's just
standing there with its claws in it and
the pigeons [ __ ]
like flooding she could not get up
and there were men trying to pull her
off there was nothing they could do and
she was just
holding down on this [ __ ] table
right she was letting her think about it
okay think about why the becky head's
throbbing right now
and now you need to [ __ ] cool off
smelling this [ __ ]
foot cheese that we're eating with this
wine right she had a girl on the [ __ ]
thing right
and also she plowed through a wine glass
in her face and with some wine and all
that so then right
they finally pull her off
somebody got real dramatic monique let
her go got real [ __ ] dramatic right
so she's escorted
off this [ __ ] set and brought into
another room
okay and then you know
the cocker spaniel check she gets up
all right now look she got her ass
kicked now there's different kinds of
ass kickings all right
there's the uh you didn't do [ __ ] you're
just in the wrong place at the wrong
time and get jumped
there's the uh hey we're gonna fight
today after school you both know it's a
fight and you lose
and then there's what i call there's an
educational ass kicking
and that's what she got she learned a
lesson
that eventually yeah you talk to someone
like me you're going to get away with it
i'll [ __ ] sit in the car as you back
out like a [ __ ] idiot
but eventually you're going to run into
somebody
who knows what you're doing and is going
to show you why that's wrong right so
they escort monique off all right the
caucus brand new lady
from the disney movie right she looks
great man she looks the exact same age
as back when they drew her all those
years ago
she [ __ ] gets up
and um
the first thing she does because now
monique is away from her and in the
other room she starts barking again
she's like you ghetto ass man all this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
and monique by the way who i got to tell
you she probably weighs 100 [ __ ]
pounds
okay but i would not want to be
that she's got grip strength i don't
know if she does pull-ups i don't know
what she does at the gym but when she
had this woman down on the table
there wasn't anything that woman the
entire cast or the whole crew could
[ __ ] do about it until
she decided that that woman was gonna
was held down enough right so now she's
in the room and this woman's of course
you know barking yeah you ghetto blah
blah whatever
and then she starts she's very calmly
which is which made it really scary she
just goes open the door and there was
this [ __ ]
producer guy i'm not i can't open the
door when he kept standing she's going
open the door
open let me out because i'm going to
kill this [ __ ]
yeah cause you know she tried to give
her an education
evidently she needs some extra help
there's going to be round two and i'm
like just let her and i'm sitting there
just watching the tv like let her go let
her go
all right this is [ __ ] great it's
like i'm watching wrestling she went
back to the dress room now she's gonna
come back
out and give her the [ __ ] i don't
know what
superfly snooker the ddt whatever your
favorite finishing move was
so she is so like just the switch was
thrown
that i am going to [ __ ] kill this
woman
that when the dude the producer i'm
sorry i can't let kelly
she just went down the stairs went
around
the entire facility and when they were
escorting lady
you know from the classic lady and the
[ __ ] escorting over the van
she tried to push through like two dudes
i don't know what happened she was out
there
in high heels too and it was like she
was pushing a tackle sled
and it was moving backwards and um so
anyway that was the fight
and at this point this is my first first
episode i ever watched i am like
i [ __ ] love this show i love this
show but then what the
what what happened was the next episode
they had this i know and i know i'm real
late this was like a couple years ago
but whatever right
they had this big sit down
with monique all of the other women
right and
i could not [ __ ] believe it none of
them took her side
not one of them they're all just like
there is no
reason to put your hands on a woman or
something all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
like
what are you talking about it's like
that that's what you say to a man
there's no reason for a guy to do it
okay you're a man don't touch a woman
but
you know there was a girl on girl action
there that was a [ __ ] level playing
field
she came walking in
i i don't i don't what was the problem
they were both looking at each other
there was a little push of little push
up and then it happened
and then she lost she [ __ ] lost and
these chicks were just [ __ ]
they didn't bring up the other ones
passive aggressive all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
all the yep and all the [ __ ] she
stuff she was doing all they talked
about
was uh was the fact that this other one
beat the [ __ ] out of her i i just
was beside myself watching first of all
one the one who shows up who thinks
she's like the beyonce of the crew
was [ __ ] late they showed up to
somebody's house right
show up to this woman's house right to
have this discussion and it's [ __ ]
hilarious
she showed up with security this is the
woman who was not even in the fight she
showed up with security because
she so couldn't deal with this other
woman being on the [ __ ] show right
she showed up with security driving a
mini cooper
with her security person in the [ __ ]
passenger seat
and then they come in the house and she
has him sitting in the kitchen
like he's having like a timeout or
something
i she um i don't know i i don't i don't
want to get because i know right now you
guys like bill i think you're going to
break down
the bruins game one win against the
islanders
um i'll try to cut to the chase here all
i know
is that they were all just
it was just all of this [ __ ] you don't
put your hands on
on anybody for any reason ever
um blah blah blah blah
and you doing this how this makes black
women look
i mean i don't know is it does that i
mean i'm not going to speak for other
people i can just say as a white guy
watching a bunch of reality shows and
seeing people that have deserved
beatdowns over the years i was so
[ __ ] thrilled
when it finally happened and then the
next [ __ ] day when lady there
whatever if candace whatever her [ __ ]
name is [ __ ]
is now playing the victim you know what
she did she put on her little college
sweatshirt
you know to show that oh i'm just a
little college girl and boo hoo boo hoo
she did that
she did that she did that [ __ ]
passive-aggressive move
oh oh did i just happen to have my
university sweatshirt on that i am an
alma mater of go
[ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself you ran
your yap and you got your [ __ ] ass
kicked and you deserved it
and all those other [ __ ] ladies on
the show they can all go [ __ ] themselves
they can all go [ __ ] themselves you know
and then you know something i actually
saw a clip because i wanted to see what
the fallout of it was
because like two of them being like i
would press charges
um i love that lady [ __ ] getting
security it's like lady your head
outweighs this woman what are you
[ __ ] worried about
[Music]
um
it's so ridiculous i went to the show i
got but then i found out she leaves the
show so [ __ ] that show
and i'm not gonna slowly watch them just
break her down
you know i don't know
i i for the life of me i i was like
i was beside myself watching that
episode when
every [ __ ] one of them sided
with the other woman um
and i was saying in here i go am i out
of my [ __ ] mind here
and she goes um
it's i think it's very you
to defend monique
what the [ __ ] does that mean i'm gonna
file that in the uh we're about to leave
uh that new segment about passive
aggressive people it's called we're
about to leave
for the we're about to leave [ __ ]
segment
let me know what uh
what what somebody did to you but i
thoroughly [ __ ] enjoyed that
and uh she didn't hurt the other woman
okay she helped her out
she helped her out because you know the
next time she does some [ __ ] like that
there's not going to be a [ __ ] camera
crew around
to break it up and then she could really
get hurt you know
but sometimes some of those people are
really i used to have a friend of mine
the [ __ ] [ __ ] he used to do and i
predicted it for [ __ ]
a decade and a half ago dude you got a
[ __ ] ass kicking coming
your way and i'm gonna i don't want to
be the guy in the middle
okay cause i don't know what your
[ __ ] deal is but you just love
picking on the biggest guy in the bar
don't you
some guy who could [ __ ] punch you
through my [ __ ] head
stop doing that right this guy was a
lunatic i mean one time we were in
[ __ ] traffic and he's such a [ __ ]
this is
way back in the day i'm talking like 30
years ago we're stuck in traffic
and he was such a competitive lunatic
there was some guy riding a harley split
in lanes
okay this is back when [ __ ] lunatics
rode harley's not just somebody who
watched uh
sons of anarchy right this was a [ __ ]
legit
outlaw looking dude right and he's
splitting lanes
and this dude [ __ ] he opened his door
started to and then closed it and i
i just think i had the bike
he just goes i wouldn't do that if i was
you
just like
i was ugh
i suppose most people was like dude do
you understand you don't know how to
fight
you don't know how to fight you're
[ __ ] with some guy in a [ __ ] i
know you guys got to have friends like
that
but if there's an art form to it
dude i got a stand-up buddy of mine i've
actually talked about it on podcast but
i want you guys to start giving them
[ __ ]
he used to [ __ ] do he was the master
of
[ __ ] i don't know what would happen he'd
get into a bar
and you'd be there like i don't know
couple two three rounds and next thing
you know he's
john was some [ __ ] mountain of a man
across the bar and he had this thing
where he would talk [ __ ]
back and up and he'd create this vacuum
and then you just find yourself
standing between him and some guy who
could beat the living
[ __ ] out of you it's just like
oh god he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then the worst thing was he would own up
to it afterwards
i'd be outside the bar going dude what
the f what do you what do you [ __ ]
mind
this was like a long time ago i'm like
i'm [ __ ] 38 years old i don't want to
i could barely fight when i was 20. what
the [ __ ] i go you don't even know how to
fight he would just be like
i know and then i couldn't be mad at him
and i would just laugh and i would be
like stop [ __ ] doing that
oh my god dude he got into it one time
with a homeless guy one of these [ __ ]
lunatics like carrying a tree branch
like [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] dude and he
was just one of these guys anybody who
walked by the homes guy's like ah
[ __ ] yeah you know it's not personal
you don't even know if he sees you this
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] you
next to you know this guy's [ __ ]
hobbling over with this tree branch
it's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
what are you doing
so anyway for years i have predicted
that people like that
i've always told them i say listen man
you have a [ __ ] ass kicking
coming like a serious [ __ ] ass
kicking coming your way and it's been my
experience
that it's it's just not true they don't
they don't and i really feel that that
woman who i teased or whatever i'm not
saying she looks like a dog
but it just was i was just upset that no
one took the yellow one side
uh the other housewife's side uh
i just i don't know
i just feel like
i don't know i don't know how to
describe it just it just drives me up
the [ __ ] wall
and there is a thing though that i talk
to my wife about when you watch those
real housewives shows like
women live i think a lot of them live by
that [ __ ] rule
of that i guess you don't put your hands
on somebody else
right and
when you watch the real housewives and
you listen to the [ __ ] that they say
each other to each other
that's why there needs to be fighting in
hockey
like people always like why do they let
them fight it's like because if they
didn't
it would be like the real housewives
except
it's men and they have clubs in their
hands
and somebody's gonna get [ __ ] killed
so what you have to have
is that guy in the motorcycle go i
wouldn't do that if i was you
you got to have that out there
the genius of those shows you get a
bunch of women in the room is they know
for the most like you know i i think
it this will probably come off as sexist
here but i mean
look what you're talking to i think the
reason why
guys get along better is because we know
there that
an ass kicking is on the table at all
times
okay no matter how much
you know of a dick you are
you there is a line you know there's a
line
even my [ __ ] you know passive
aggressive friends that i have
they know there's a line that's why
they're backing up they're not
walking toward they're backing up
because they know this guy's going to
[ __ ] kill me
but now i get you know i got to do a
little bravado [ __ ] to save my [ __ ]
you know manhood hit or whatever but
like
i really feel like because
you know like maybe that's why i didn't
say anything that guy we're about to
leave and it's like oh
you know i'm putting i'm about to put a
kid in the car you sweaty [ __ ] [ __ ]
now i don't know what this guy does
how do i know he's not some retired dojo
master next thing you know
i'm seeing the underside of my car is
the last thing i remember is he flips me
upside down
so that's the thing like and i think
with those shows because
there's no enforcer there's no bob
probert
you know patrolling the seas that [ __ ]
just [ __ ] gets out of hand and it was
so nice
to finally see somebody who just
deserved a [ __ ] ass kick and
just get it i loved it
i [ __ ] loved it great show but now i
heard she left so i'll [ __ ] that show
um whatever but if you're a hockey fan
you know and if you don't like real
housewives watch that episode
and i'm telling you like a bird of prey
she just [ __ ]
held her down on that sticky table
all right i accidentally hit stop i was
trying to see how much time i did there
all right let's let's talk bruins
the big bad bruins um
win game one versus the uh new york
islanders
it was a uh an incredible game through
about two periods
then the bruins blew it open in uh the
third period but um
my takeaways um
after the first period when i was
texting with a buddy of mine he goes
what do you think it was one to one
um i've said i was like well i think the
islanders it's very even
very easily matched i think the
islanders might be a little bit
faster but for some reason i think we
have a little more experience so
hopefully
that's gonna um be the uh
the difference in the series but i was
telling another buddy of mine i was
putting some money on the game i'm going
this is like so evenly matched
uh i want us you know i almost feel like
game one's
a must-win because i don't see either
team blowing a lead
a series lead you know if they're up a
game on you i just don't see them
blowing a series lead alright uh
which i will get to with another [ __ ]
team
in the nhl that's driving me up the wall
uh but anyways
uh pastor knock had a hat trick um
just two of his goals the patience that
the man has with the puck
taylor hall on the third one creating
traffic out front
he's just been playing great and he's
been just been such a factor that he's
out on the ice and gives us two legit
lines
and has to kind of make the other team
decide
how they're going to match up against us
i think is opening it up for our our
top line and um i thought tuca played
great
um you know i got a little
nervous when grizzly went down but uh he
came back like a [ __ ] champ
um because i guess miller is still out
so we're gonna be getting a little uh
a little [ __ ] uh thin on defense but
uh
charlie mcavoy i love that he [ __ ]
bodied that guy threw him down on the
[ __ ] ice
as much as i loved his goal um i think
he's really starting to use his size
uh physically too which is great to see
um and he's still just a kid and i just
think he's got such an amazing career
ahead of him
so we shall see i haven't said that the
great joe bartnik let me know that the
abs are the team to beat this
obviously with each round it's going to
get harder and harder so we'll see what
happens
i think this is going to go like
um one of those back and forth back and
forth back and forth throughout the
whole thing and hopefully we'll come out
on top but the islanders got a really
good
really good team and a great coach who
just won a cup with [ __ ] washington a
few years ago so
um a huge huge win all right and with
that let's talk about the
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] toronto
maple leafs i swear to [ __ ] god i
don't know why
when did i take on the misery of this
franchise
i just this you know what it is it's
it's how much i hate the montreal
canadiens i just know that the leafs
having any success
would add to the misery of montreal
canadian fans
as they now are almost 30 30 years in
on the curse of patrick wah they booed
him out of the building
because they thought their next ken
dryden was coming or whatever the [ __ ]
they thought
they forgot there was 30 teams in the
league and it wasn't like the old days
when there was only six teams or a six
in the expansion six
or whatever if you really look at the
canadians dominance it [ __ ]
ended it [ __ ] ended
right uh when they brought in all of
those [ __ ] teams from the ihl
that was it it was too many [ __ ]
teams it just
ended and ever since then they've won
two cups and they used to win two cups
every [ __ ] three years they were
incredible
[ __ ] incredible um so anyway
i start rooting for the leafs because i
always root for you know i rooted for
the kansas city royals
the [ __ ] the the capitals the [ __ ]
cubs anytime there's somebody they're
gonna they're gonna end a long streak
and not [ __ ] winning
unless they're playing my team i root
for them okay
so i see i watch game four
the [ __ ] leafs win it's three games
to one
but i've been watching the leafs long
enough that even i knew when i tweeted i
just said hey
there's something going on really
interesting in a certain canadian
city that this bruins fan
is finding interesting or whatever i
said because i didn't want to jinx them
doesn't [ __ ] matter doesn't [ __ ]
matter
the series was three to one okay
game five they can close it out
okay it goes into overtime they give it
up on their own end
canadians win now it's three games to
two
last night i watched the game i missed
the game before i watched the game last
night okay
you know slipping back and forth you
know between the
mainly watching the bruins obviously but
it's like wow the bruins gonna win game
one
and i'm gonna see toronto close out the
[ __ ]
montreal canadiens right they [ __ ]
they're down suddenly i flipped back
it's two to nothing
canadians i'm like oh my god not again
not a [ __ ] kid right
then you know whatever the bruins are
[ __ ] doing well as a commercial break
i flip back
i see the uh toronto's bench is going
nuts
and i see that it's two to one and i'm
sitting there looking like did they just
make it two to two or is it two to one
it's like two to one i'm like [ __ ]
there's like six minutes left
i'm flipping back and forth and flipping
back and forth and then all of a sudden
they [ __ ] score they tie it up 2-2
they're going into overtime they're
gonna end it in montreal let's [ __ ]
go let's [ __ ] go
what do they do they play a great
overtime
and then they give it up on their own
end and
uh one of those [ __ ] shots that just
gets
deflected knuckleball was that a
knuckleball i think that one i think
last two the one that beat carrie price
great goaltender
uh just clipped the um defenseman skate
and at that point it's like yeah like
trying to hit a [ __ ] knuckleball
and they just miss it so now it is three
games to three and as you're listening
to this
um game seven will be tonight
okay and um
i haven't given up hope because i know
that the maple leafs eventually are
going to get over this
hump and when they do they're not going
to make it easy on their fans
they're not just going to beat the
[ __ ] canadians they're going to have
to almost [ __ ] it up
and then they're gonna do it and i think
that they're gonna do it i feel like
they got enough
you know i think they got enough in the
tank i think they have enough stars
i don't think like last year where they
were just like sort of top heavy where
they just had all this offense and no
defense um
i'm praying to god i'm praying to god
because i'll tell you right now if i if
they [ __ ] lose this series
and i was the mayor of toronto i would
buy
i don't know what the city is built on
top of but like they need some sort of
poltergeist woman to come in there
the biggest i don't know bundle of sage
to be burned
something has to happen something has
got to [ __ ] happen but uh you know
when they beat them
in montreal a few games back that's the
first they were like that's the first
time
they've beaten the canadians in a
playoff game in montreal since 1967.
my old ass was born in 68 so my entire
life they've never done that
now granted you know they haven't met in
the playoffs since 1980 and they were in
a different conference for almost
[ __ ] 20 years
20 seasons at least so um
you know it is what it is but uh
i cannot tell you how hard i'm pulling
for the [ __ ] lease because
part of the stanley cup tradition
is becoming seeing that shot of all of
those maple leaf fans
standing outside what is it i forget the
name of it
where they play the new maple leaf
gardens right
standing outside that [ __ ] place
excited
waving towels going crazy in the
beginning and then watching it slowly
slip away
until it's just this grassy knoll of
like [ __ ]
18 fans scattered across it
it's just this satisfy it's like one
there's two [ __ ] things
if you want to see something sad every
year watch the maple leafs blow it in
the playoffs
and watch somebody watch the masters
you know watch the masters on the final
day and you have you have like a
with both things you have a chance of
seeing just the ultimate sports [ __ ]
meltdown um
anyway uh looks like stuff is opening up
i'm very excited
looks like my tour is a go i cannot wait
i did stand up
at the uh the comedy store on um
on uh friday night
went down there and uh worked on some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] around and uh
i just you know just seeing comics
seeing the wait staff everybody else
you know just richie everybody down
there was just [ __ ] awesome
and i cannot wait um
it looks like we're finally on the other
side of this get out there
people make some money come out have a
good time and go see some
orange bald idiot like me would be great
um
all right that's it with that let's uh
let's do a little bit of the advertising
here
see what we got here all right
uh bambi when running a business
hr issues can kill you can kill you uh
hr
human resources that's such a cold name
human resources uh
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements
labor regulations
hey you can't stick that child in there
to [ __ ]
lift up that heavy stuff ah these damn
regulations
an hr manager salaries aren't cheap
an average of thousand dollars a year
bambi spell b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for small b all
right this is for small businesses okay
here we go
this was to help out corporations i was
like they already lawyered up
uh you can get a dedicated hr manager
craft hr policy and maintain your
compliance
all for just 99 dollars a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from on boarding to terminations
they customize your policy
wait a minute well i guess if you get
hired online to work at some
local deli then they can fire you online
that that wouldn't be weird
anyway they customize your policies to
fit your business and help you manage
your employees
day to day all for just 99
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on hr
compliance let bambi help get your free
hr audit today go to bambi.com
right now to schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi b-a-m-b-e-e
like bambi the insect dot-com slash burr
spelled bam
uh to the b-e-e dot com slash burr who
they went a little uh whitney houston
hell to the no
bam to the b-e-e dot com slash burp all
right
and lastly but not leastly
um it's policy genius
summer's here guys and days are getting
longer
meaning you've got some you got some
extra time to see if you're overpaying
for home and auto insurance
as adults summer fun includes saving
money
policy genius is a free and easy way to
check if you could be saving cash
on what you're paying for a home and on
what you're paying
for home and auto insurance are your
home and auto policies almost up for
renewal
let policy genius look for a lower rate
for you christ you're throwing money
away
policy genius makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price price sorry they've
saved customers an average of 1
250 per year over what they were paying
for home and auto insurance
their team will handle the paperwork to
set your new policy
to set up your new policy or switch over
your current one how it works getting
started is easy
first head to policygenius.com and
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property the policy
gene
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's
top insurers from progressive to
allstate to find your lowest quotes
the palsy genius team can look for ways
to save you more
including bundling your home and auto
policies if they
found a if they find a better rate than
what you're paying now they'll switch
you over for free
uh their top-notch service has earned
policy genius an excellent rating on
trust
pilot head to policygenius.com to get
started right now if you're dumb like me
you don't know how to spell genius i'll
spell it out
policy p-o-l-i-c-y genius g-e-n-i-u-s
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right okay
now last week somebody asked me about a
prenup i forget what the [ __ ] i said
but uh you you listeners did not agree
with me
um so here we go prenups decent argument
hey billy blank balls we mean blank
balls i just had a [ __ ] kid
how dare you late in the game too uh not
a lady here but i have recently heard a
good argument in favor of prenups when
extreme
wealth is involved i got to be honest
with you i kind of feel like in the
future
um as women start to make the same
amount of money as men
then they're going to be all about
prenups because we know how it works
with them right
we know how it works it's they have to
be happy so if all of a sudden
enough women start [ __ ] having to pay
[ __ ] child support and alimony
they're gonna be like wait wait wait
wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute we need to
take a look at what's going on
here right ladies right they're gonna do
that [ __ ]
but that doesn't exist right now so
anyway firstly the argument shies away
from the situation where a
where a lack of trust is present between
the partners rather presents the real
risk
of predatory family members of which
they may have
and lack control over oh so you take the
focus off of her and put it on her
[ __ ] up family how does that work
these people come out of the woodwork
and can destabilize newlyweds
where extreme wealth is involved prenup
for situations like these can probably
be the difference between lasting
marriages and divorces within a year
also many pre-nups have degenerative
qualities that make them meaningless
after
x amount of years thanks a lot for
everything yeah i
i don't know what you're saying but
there there's a lot of loopholes in that
um but you know i guess you can do it
you know i don't know you should have
like a prenup that protects whatever you
had before
you got together because how it works is
whatever you did while you're with
that person they get all the credit
which is hilarious
it's [ __ ] hilarious if they weren't
at your job doing the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] hilarious well i was at
home watching the kids well i could have
[ __ ] hired a nanny
a full-time [ __ ] nanny that well that
wouldn't you know at the end of her
time working with me want to take half
of whatever the [ __ ] i created at work
all right prenups dear bill you pale
irish redheaded [ __ ] boy jesus christ
um i heard your response to the guy who
wrote in about the prenup
and you have it all wrong as usual
maybe i do that on purpose to keep uh to
keep listeners um
sure there are women who you refer to as
predators
but that's not the norm how the [ __ ] do
you know do you date women
um what's more i'm assuming this is a
woman i should
what's more likely to happen is this guy
will continue to kill it with his
business
and years of resentment will slowly
build about some [ __ ]
like they do in all marriages and things
will fall apart
that's not her being a predator that's
just life
wait a second wait a second
so if one person is killing it
in the marriage and the other person
resents them for it
that's not the resentful person needing
to work on themselves that's just life
are they ever held responsible for
anything
jesus christ it's like how many guys
does wilson have to hit on the ice and
still get the [ __ ] capitals on a
[ __ ] power play it's unbelievable
uh that's not her being a predator just
life so this poor bastard will work his
tail off giving her a great life
and she'll be pissed about some [ __ ]
and things will fall apart
either way this guy is getting screwed i
guess i make way
more money than my wife and resent her
every day for it so i guess that [ __ ]
goes both ways
oh you resent her yeah yeah because
she's still this like
i dude i know what you're talking about
better advice would have
been don't get married before you're 40.
well
i at least did that also boston is a
dirty place and go [ __ ] yourself
um i actually have a [ __ ] theory that
um
that like i think women always look for
a problem in the relationship
because it's how they maintain a sense
of control
because if it's just going well and
you're doing well and you don't have
anything to work
on um or you guys don't have anything to
work out they i think they feel like
there's no connection there
you're gonna get bored or whatever um
but you know my wife is amazing but i've
even had to have those conversations
it's like can i go
three days without being in the doghouse
i mean like what is the [ __ ] problem
look at that flat screen tv huh what is
the [ __ ] problem
i tell [ __ ] jokes and we get to live
here what is the problem
i know sorry and then they do that and
then yo
everything's great you're [ __ ]
sharing a malt you know what i mean or
some spaghetti
to bring back lady and the [ __ ] and
then like [ __ ] three days later okay
yeah i just gotta say
[Laughter]
you just want to just stick them in a
hamper close the lid
um dirty harry dear billy color truck
burr uh
i am from india what's going on i
[ __ ] love you
people um that's like progressive and uh
offensive all the same time i was just
thinking about you guys today
you guys meeting people from india how
much fun i had over there
what like next level ball breakers you
oh i know what it was
i saw yet another white chick bitching
or whatever
and i have like this theory you know
it's not even a theory it's like
actually a fact like the more oppressed
you are the funnier you are
you're just [ __ ] funny you know
white women generally speaking
they're not really breaking up the party
go over to india everybody over there
packed in like sardines you guys were
[ __ ] hilarious
um oh i divide on this podcast i am from
india and i have been a huge fan of the
podcast which is what is keeping me sane
in these
times heard you mention the dirty dirty
harry's
by the way when i say white women i'm
not talking about comedians before you
guys try to turn this into some [ __ ] i'm
just talking about
you know the white broads in the crowd
just getting all offended and all of
that crap and i'm not talking about all
of them
i'm just talking about the loud ones i
heard you mentioned dirty
mentioned the dirty harry series in the
last episode and was wondering whether
you knew it was based on a true story
and he writes yeah it's about the zodiac
killer and how the police tried to solve
the mystery
and also other such cases from the past
from 1981
germany in 1972 victoria uh
uh australia the callahan character
in dirty harry seeks out a psycho killer
serial killer like the zodiac killer in
the movie as well
um that movie was shot in 1970 when was
the zodiac killer i don't even know
you also see the dirty harry movie being
referenced in the zodiac movie which
came out in 2007.
also since you mentioned the 40 drives
in dirty harry
thought you might find it cool to know
about clint eastwood's car collection
i would actually and i had it wrong that
that plymouth satellite that he drove
through the front of the [ __ ]
liquor store in the beginning was uh
that was just a car he trashed he drove
another ford i forget what it was
in um
in the uh what was that one called the
enforcer
uh clint eastwood's car collection will
make your day
all right let me see it ford roadster
1932.
is he a ford guy just when i couldn't
love this guy anymore
lincoln k series convertible 1937.
now he's born in 1930.
so these are all the cars from his uh
childhood austin healey
100 m i don't know what that means 1955
can i get some pictures here
cadillac el dorado series 62.
i already know what that one looks like
convertible 1955. oh because i'm on the
wrong [ __ ]
christ is he on that internet i'm on the
wi-fi here all right let's see what i
got here
there we go look at clint how could this
guy not be a [ __ ] movie star
um 1932 roadster look at that badass
thing i can't believe he can get in
there
guys like six four i don't have too much
of a man crush on him
lincoln k series convertible
it's like a classic you know that's
either a mob boss or the mayor of a
filthy town car
um austin healey that 55 is amazing
amazing car yep and that cadillac el
dorado series 62 1955 is one of the best
looking cadillacs ever made
two door god that's gorgeous gorgeous
car
jaguar xk 150 roadster 1960. my favorite
jag is the one that steve mcqueen had in
the 1950s whatever that one is
morris mini countryman cooper 1966.
this is this is a real car guy that if
you have this thrown in there
ferrari 275 gtb
1966 i don't know much about the
ferraris other than the ones from the
60s
are like priceless gran torino sport oh
that's what he had he had
a gran torino that's right he had a gran
torino
and um the enforcer
and he was you know he wasn't into like
women's lib
he just kept going well isn't that fancy
and then years later he's just
you know get off my lawn in gran torino
how cool is that
i wonder if he used his actual car for
the movie uh ferrari 365
365 gt4 berlinetta boxer
1974.
pontiac special edition trans am 1977. i
wonder what the special edition was
that's the the burt reynolds one ferrari
308 gtb
gmc typhoon 1992 what the [ __ ] is that
a few years ago when jimmy fallon's at
tonight's show eastwood was asked what
he drives
uh this isn't gq magazine i'm gonna read
this i don't have time to go through all
this he's got a fiat 500e
i love that [ __ ] car
i think that's all the cars that's
amazing
that is really amazing um anyways that's
on gq magazine
the uk edition dirty harry
uh dirty harry clint eastwood's uh
car collection anyway anyways that's it
just thought it might be fascinating to
share the above
big fan love the podcast thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself all right refuse to touch
laptop dear
billy boo berry a few days ago because
i'm white as a ghost is that what that
is
a few days ago i was at my friend's and
he asked me to search from
something on youtube on his computer
i flat out said no i'm not touching your
jizz machine
he got all offended like i was saying he
jerked off for an unreasonably
or unhealthy amount i told him that
wasn't the case i know he doesn't clean
his keyboard
and he most likely is 99.99 of humans
who jerk off the porn
how is this not why a widely
acknowledged thing
i'm not going to use your toothbrush i'm
not going to let you [ __ ] my wife and
i'm not
touching your computer is what you
should have wrote you said your
toothbrush thoughts dude i thank you i
think you're on the cutting edge
the cutting edge i think that's a great
[ __ ] point
i want people out there who uh who who
are these people
people who work on computers i mean you
gotta you can't tell me that you don't
[ __ ]
you must wipe it down away like those
[ __ ] i'm gonna commit a murder gloves
um that's a great point
i'll tell you what's nuts was back in
the day used to use the pay phone like
in new york city i'd take a payphone
stick it right to my [ __ ] ear
um that other the mouthpiece touching my
lower jaw
awful girlfriend's ex is a pro athlete
hey billy bongo tits jesus christ i'm
getting trashed here
uh i'm a 21 year old guy living in
canada i'm dating this amazing
beautiful smart girl with a great sense
of humor
uh we have been great together for about
six months
and it's going great we're getting more
serious so she's been she has been
digging into
so we have been digging into each
other's past
and she tells me that her ex is a pro
hockey player
he's a very high profile player and he
is quite well known especially here in
canada
she started dating him throughout high
school wow okay
whether her ex is playing in town he
will
whenever his ex is playing in town he
will send my girl's mom tickets for the
hockey game apparently this guy and my
girl's mom
get along really well a little too well
no
she hasn't gone to a game in over a year
she has been totally faithful and i have
zero fear
she will cheat or anything like that she
really is amazing i absolutely hate that
her ex is this famous good-looking fit
millionaire i'm definitely a good
looking guy but i'm no pro athlete
my girl doesn't bring him up at all but
she works hard on our relationship
i know it's not fair to her but i can't
help thinking that she sees me
in no way as good as her ex
well dude i mean
if that's what she thought then she
would dump your ass in a minute at the
very least try to go land another hockey
player
hanging out at games i think anyways not
to get all depressing
but i don't know how to compete on top
of all that i cringe whenever i'm
watching hockey now
am i just crazy to be thinking like that
i would definitely ha
say i have lots of self-confidence
i have never had an issue with comparing
myself to people but this guy
is really getting to me your advice
would be great thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself uh you gotta work your way
through that man
if she's not going with this guy or any
of that type of [ __ ]
um
you know you know what i would do i
would start working on yourself
you become an even better version than
you are right now i mean there's a
reason why they broke up
for all you know she just thinks the
guy's a douche maybe he's great at this
one thing and he sucks at being a
boyfriend
or whatever i think it's a great thing
that uh despite the fact him being
famous and being a great looking guy and
a pro athlete
you know if she walked away from that
thing
then um obviously
she knows that you know money and looks
and that thing
you know are not all that it's cracked
up to be so what i would do
is i go out there you know hit the gym a
little harder
work on yourself you know if you got any
[ __ ] issues that might [ __ ] up the
relationship i i don't know what to tell
you i've never been in that situation
but i gotta say if she's not going to
games and she doesn't seem to give a
[ __ ]
um you know but i get it
i get it that guy's just out there
circling like a shark right on your flat
screen tv every [ __ ] night that's got
to be tough
so i do have empathy for you but what i
would do is i would that's just one of
those things like i have no [ __ ]
control over that
so whatever gives a [ __ ] you live once
throw yourself in this relationship be a
great boyfriend if she [ __ ] dumps you
for
uh whoever the [ __ ] this guy is then
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna [ __ ] do you know
what you do you then go out and put out
a hit album like that [ __ ] chick over
there in england
you know that chick that whatever
whatever i wish we get a [ __ ] name
daddy from the other side
whatever that song that [ __ ] huge
voice man amazing amazing singer
and she's funny as hell too what the
[ __ ] you know she got dumped
so there you go hang with this chick and
then someday when she breaks up with you
you write the male alanis morris set
album
that's what you do mr
duplicity um
be funny if she dumps you and then you
just [ __ ] give her [ __ ] as she's
walking out the door
like all hockey terms yeah go again go
back to him
go back he's a minus six a plus four
four years of being the best boyfriend
you're ever gonna have
right just go down swinging
all right dilemma uh
hey billy boy scout billy boy scout got
a couple of dilemmas
for you one would you rather have
everyone chuckled dismissively
at everything you say as if nothing you
say
is important or never or never be able
to make anyone laugh
ever again oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
just tied me up with a goddamn
what do i do with that
uh i would definitely much rather have
the first chuckled dismissively there
i would just there's no [ __ ] way i
would be crying laughing by the third
person and then what i would do
is i would then the game would then just
be i would just keep making statements
and the statements would get bigger and
bigger and more ridiculous
because then their reaction they should
be saying what the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] can you say that but if
they're then chuckling dismissively it
then becomes funny for me and then i'm
having a great time
that's what it'd be but to never make
anybody laugh again that's how i connect
with people
um anyway he had a number two but i
don't know anyone getting that number
two one that one's just
crossing a line keep it about me huh
people keep it about me
um all right that is the podcast
everybody i hope you enjoyed it
um i hope you have a wonderful week it's
coming into june
june is right around the corner um
my my little boy is is walking dude he
is
he's i don't be the overly proud dad kid
jacked he's got a little physique on him
he's got some shoulders
you know he's got a little chest on him
i didn't want to say anything i just saw
yeah maybe it's kind of baby fat or
whatever just shaped like that the roles
and all the all the [ __ ] you know
all the ladies you know mom
mother-in-law everybody you know is
going like he's kind of uh
strong right so yesterday
my daughter right we had come back i
took her to the park we were riding
bikes and [ __ ] right
and she was sitting there she had a
little
little thing of snacks and i he was
whining wanted to be up on the couch i
brought him on the couch and he just
looked
at the snacks he just reached out and he
just grabbed the bag
and she's going nobody no and he just
starts pulling it
with one hand towards himself
and my daughter's trying to pull it back
oh no no no no and he just pulled it and
just took it right out of her hand
and then she looks at me you know like
can you believe that and i just said
well you got to take it back
don't let people do that to you right so
i don't know he's got like a vice grip
on him
he's a little grippy guy he just [ __ ]
grabs on to you he's got a great sense
of humor and now he's walking
hilarious when he walks he has his hands
up like he's on a roller coaster you
know those people they put i don't know
why they do it
you put your hands up on a roller
coaster i don't know why i don't know
why people do that
all right i don't know why people stick
their legs out motorcycle racing when
they go around a turn
balance i have no idea what it is but
anyways when he walks he's got his he's
got his hands up
um and right now he finally
has confidence because he's been walking
for about four weeks and now he's just
kind of like
you know if i uh
he now he's just like i would rather
walk than
crawl that's his deal um all right that
is it
that is it that is the uh that is the
podcast i hope you guys have a wonderful
week
go [ __ ] yourselves go bruins what about
those celtics huh
how about those celtics last game you
know we finally got those [ __ ]
brooklyn nets
all right i mean they shouldn't be
called like the brooklyn ness they just
there's one of those [ __ ] oceans 11
teams
you know at at center brad pitt
power forward matt damon don cheadle
shooting guard
get coming and they still need one more
piece coming down out of the locker room
george clooney
one of those [ __ ] teams just
everybody's a superstar on it
so who knows maybe we can win two in
this series we'll see what the [ __ ]
happens
um just jason tatum i mean i don't know
what
you can say i just wish his partner in
crime uh jalen brown was there
because i think we could actually give
these guys a series um
but i really miss the days when people
took chances on draft picks and there
was the excitement to see whether they
worked out or not
rather than just raiding somebody else's
team as somebody has already proved that
they can dominate at the pro level
i just don't see the skill set there's
no salary cap it's not competition it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
and we're all just sitting around
waiting for the nets to play the lakers
that's basically what's happening
i'm holding out on utah to maybe stop
the lakers we'll see all right that's it
i will talk to you guys on thursday
you